- Good afternoon, everyone.
Marta and I are heartened
to see you on our screens.
And we're joined today by Secretary
and Vice President of University
Life, Kimberly Goff-Crews,
Yuliia Zhukovets, a junior
in Franklin College,
and University Chaplain, Sharon Kugler.
To everyone online, thank
you for taking the time
to participate in this vigil for peace.
All of us recognize
that the world is in a
somber, perilous place.
And over the past few days,
I've watched with horror,
as I know you have, Vladimir
Putin's invasion of Ukraine.
Putin's aggression against a
sovereign independent nation
raises the specter of prolonged
conflict throughout Europe.
This is the largest
ground attack in Europe
since World War II.
We know from history that
the risks of miscalculation
are dangerously high.
And at Yale, we are compelled
by our common sense of humanity
to reject this violence
in the strongest terms.
We stand for peace.
We grieve for the lives lost.
We also support the students and scholars
of the Yale Ukrainian community,
and those Yale students and scholars
from elsewhere in the
region, including Russia,
who I am confident do not
support this invasion.
I know many of our students and colleagues
are shocked and distressed.
They fear for the future
and for the safety of
loved ones and friends.
Over the past week, Yale staff and faculty
have been reaching out
to them to offer support.
For example,
the Office of International
Students and Scholars
is working with each affected student.
They're helping them with
post-graduation plans,
employment authorizations,
and travel needs.
We're monitoring developments
regarding immigration options
and sharing with students and
scholars relevant updates.
For undergraduates from
Ukraine on financial aid,
we will reevaluate the financial
aid awards they receive
if there are changes in
your economic situation.
We're advocating for policies
that protect the legal status
of Ukrainian students
and scholars in the US
during and beyond their studies here.
We're supporting consultations
with immigration attorneys
for Ukrainian students and
scholars who need assistance
in navigating their future
status in the United States.
In the days ahead, we'll continue to work
with individual students
in any way we can.
In addition, faculty members on our campus
are helping policymakers
think through how to respond.
The coming weeks, the Jackson Institute
will be hosting an
expert panel discussion.
We will hear from faculty members
who have long studied
the history of the region
and can share insights
into the current conflict,
and anticipate what may come
next and how we can respond.
I very much hope the scholars
and creative thinkers of our community
can help the world chart
a path toward peace.
Right now, the spirit of
division around the globe
seems stronger than ever.
We must respond by embracing
the ways we are connected.
Not all of us work or study in fields
that can contribute solutions directly
to global conflicts of this kind,
but all of us play vital roles
in creating an environment of
peace and belonging at Yale,
and within all communities
of which we are a part.
So let us treat one another and ourselves
with kindness and understanding.
Let us approach our lives
with gratitude and with mindfulness.
During this time of
crisis, it gives me hope
when I see our community's commitment
to one another and to peace.
Please keep in mind, in your minds,
the families and friends who
are in the Ukraine right now,
withstanding, and surviving,
and combating this unjustified barrage.
Thank you for joining us.
I'll now turn things over to Secretary
and Vice President for University
Life, Kimberly Goff-Crews.
- Thank you, President Salovey.
I join the president in welcoming everyone
to this vigil for peace.
We are here to support
our Ukraine faculty,
students, staff, and alumni,
as well as those with ties to Ukraine,
and to find strength in one another.
Some of you may have been at
the rally on campus today,
and I know that there are other
events going on this week,
including one today with the symphony.
Tonight, we create a virtual space
to join people around the world
in praying for an end to war
in Ukraine and for peace.
We know that events that
seem rather distanced
have global effects.
They can touch people around us
and the people who are important to them.
Of course, we do not need to
have personal ties to Ukraine
to feel shock, fear, and
anger, and to wish for peace.
Some of you here this evening
may have experienced
violence or war yourself.
We are grateful for your
presence and solidarity.
We're profoundly affected
by this week's events
because we care for humanity
in Ukraine, in the world, and at Yale.
So I encourage all of us to
look out for one another,
especially people in your
social communities, classes,
and work settings as we
process what is happening.
If you need it, I encourage
you to seek support,
whether from your school
or residential college,
mental health and counseling,
the chaplain's office,
our employee assistance programs,
or of course, from friends and family.
As these events unfold,
we will support members of our community
from Ukraine, Russia, and the region
in the ways that President
Salovey described.
We've got you.
We really got you.
And we will continue Yale's
important work to serve humanity
and to make for a safer,
healthier, more equitable world.
Before I turn to our next speaker,
I would like to share
some of Martin Luther King Jr.'s remarks
when he received the Nobel Prize in 1964.
He was speaking about
the nuclear arms race.
His words have resonance tonight.
He said, "So we must fix our vision
not merely on the
negative expulsion of war,
but upon the positive
affirmation of peace.
We must see that peace
represents a sweeter music,
a cosmic melody that is far
superior to the discords of war.
Somehow we must transform the dynamics
of the world's power struggle
from a negative to a positive contest
to harness man's creative genius
for the purpose of making
peace and prosperity
a reality for all of the
nations of the world.
If we have the will and determination
to mount such peace to such
a peace offensive," he said,
"We will unlock tightly
sealed doors of hope
and transform our imminent cosmic elegy
into a psalm of creative fulfillment."
Again, thank you for joining us.
I will now turn to Yuliia Zhukovets,
a junior in Yale College
and a citizen of Ukraine.
- Hi, everyone.
Thank you, Peter, and thank you, Kimberly
for everything you said.
My name is Yuliia and
I'm a junior in Franklin,
and I was born and
raised in Kyiv, Ukraine.
As President Salovey and
Kimberly have already mentioned,
an unthinkable is happening right now
in my home country in Ukraine.
On the 24th of February at 5:00 am,
Putin invaded Ukraine,
invaded my home country,
and forever changed my life
and lives of millions of other Ukrainians.
I was lucky enough to not be
there when everything started
and not to be there right now,
and I understand and
acknowledge how lucky I am,
but millions of people
who are still in Ukraine
are not that lucky.
Everyone who is still in the major cities
and in the areas of
active military actions
have to spend days and nights
hiding in the bomb shelters,
trying to protect themselves
against the Russian missile attacks.
However, the Ukrainian army
has been extremely successful
with fighting the Russian forces.
We won most of the ground battles,
and we continue to stop
the Russian invasion
and continue to stop them
against progressing
further into the country.
It is really tough being away from home
and not being able to
be there for my family,
but I hope as most of you know,
there was a 2:00 pm rally
for Ukraine across campus,
and by this, I'm trying
to support my country,
support my family, and do everything I can
being thousands of miles away.
I have received incredible
support from the administration,
from my fellow students, from
other Ukrainians at Yale,
and Yale math school,
and Yale Divinity School,
and from Yale New Haven Hospital.
The support that Yale has
given me has been incredible,
and I cannot imagine a
better place to be right now.
I urge all of you to take a minute today
to think how lucky and privileged you are
to be away from the war right now,
and how lucky you are to be in the US,
or wherever you are right
now where you're attending,
and not to be in the active military zone
where the war against humanity,
the war against one of the
oldest nations in Europe,
the genocide of Ukrainian
people is happening right now.
Thank you all for coming here.
This means a lot to me.
This means a lot to my family.
Thank you for tuning in.
And I'm gonna pass it to Sharon Kugler,
the University Chaplain.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Yuliia.
You've shown such grace
and strength this last week
and our prayers are with you.
My beloved Yale family.
this is a vigil calling for peace,
and my words are intended
to both amplify that call
and turn it into action.
Our world, this beautiful
yet imperfect world
that we all share, breaks a
little bit more every day.
We have been living with a
deep burden of global unrest,
uncertainty, grief, and fear
that is starting to feel
brutally defiant in its staying power.
Our spirits are suffering
under the stress of it all.
And now, here we are,
gathered in this imperfect way
across these many screens,
longing for connection,
for reasons to hope, longing
for multiple kinds of peace.
What can we do thousands of
miles away from a new war,
a new invasion, to bring peace?
This is a vigil calling for peace.
Peace in Ukraine where
people are fleeing, hiding,
or preparing to lose their very lives
in defense of their
home, their way of life.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
Peace in all places where
aggression, poverty, ignorance,
and violence oppresses and
destroys our human family.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
Peace in our aching hearts,
so that we can find the
strength to keep going
and to be part of a kind of
healing that is restorative.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
Peace in our minds so that we can use them
to create a more just world
where power of means or might is used
to elevate the human condition
and to cherish our planet.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
Peace in our relationships with others,
where we can see and be seen
for the uniquely beautiful mysteries
contained in each of us.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
Peace in the light, peace in the dark,
peace in the big, peace in the small,
peace in the weak, peace in the strong.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
One of my favorite prayers is also a hymn.
It's the Prayer of St. Francis.
In its entirety, it's a
distinctly Christian prayer.
However, the first part feels
accessible to all people,
and it is in this moment, a
much needed balm for the soul.
The prayer asks for us to be
instruments of God's peace.
The prayer reveals that
making peace is in our hands.
Lord, make me an instrument of your peace.
Where there is hatred, let me so love.
Where there is injury, pardon.
Where there is doubt, faith.
Where there is despair, hope.
Where there is darkness, light.
Where there is sadness, joy.
This is a vigil calling for peace.
May you be shalom.
May you be salaam.
May you be shanti.
May you bring peace.
I now invite you to join me in
observing a moment of silence
honoring those across the
world, particularly in Ukraine,
who have been lost,
those who are grieving,
and those living in fear for
what might be coming next.
Focus simply on being still.
Let your mind turn to what it might mean
to be an instrument of peace.
Thank you.
This concludes the formal
part of this vigil.
I invite you to linger a
bit in this Zoom space.
We have arranged for a
couple of pieces of music
to be played to soothe your soul.
Let the music bless you,
and then please feel free
to leave when you are ready,
and perhaps seek out a friend
to connect with over dinner this evening,
call a family member just to check in,
or introduce yourself to someone new,
and be an instrument of peace.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
Peace be with you and God
bless the people of Ukraine.